everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie today we're going to continue
with the styling that we were doing
yesterday so I did a little bit of work
on it
between yesterday stream and now so I'll
catch you up with the work that I have
done and then we'll keep at it let's see
I did want to let you all know in case
anybody can make it to the the node
member conference that I'm going to be
speaking at Nashville at the end of
November I don't know if anybody is in
that area or is planning on being there
but if you are I know when and where I
will be speaking so I thought I'd share
that with you all you can go on the
November site and check it out whenever
you want but I just figured I'd I put
that on there so I will be on Tuesday it
will be Tuesday November 20 I think it's
a 28th at 4:00 p.m. so not bad get this
timeslot right before the keynote
speaker so I don't know if that's as
good or bad but I'll be one of the last
speakers all right so let me get I don't
have my live chat window open yet let me
get that open
okay
it looks like someone was kneeling so AR
wants me to link the site I'm gonna put
a link to the site that we're working on
and the live chat right now all right so
I've changed some some minor details but
I think there are important details not
everybody who would notice them but it's
important for consistency so it's going
to be hard to tell without a
side-by-side of the old version but what
we've done is we've added a different
shadow and we've changed the border
radius before the border radius was
three pixels now it's two pixels that
might not seem like a big deal but we
use two pixels for everything unless
something's changed the last time I
checked for material design the standard
was a two pixel border radius so we
switch that up we have the proper
shadows now the shadows were different
we have a new button the colors may or
may not change I just copied these over
from another form that I had done so we
have let's see we're gonna have to
change that border radius so I was right
in the middle getting this button
changed whenever I started the stream so
let's make sure that that border radius
is correct we now have the correct
shadow and the correct effect when we
hover over it okay we've gone with the
all-caps for the text and a slightly
thicker for the font the font so all
changed to we're going to change the
font family and then other than changing
the font family changing the color of
these it's probably the last thing that
we need to do yeah because this this
effect is exactly what I want so I'm
really glad that this is the default
effect that way we don't have to worry
about trying to
like this okay
all right so let's finish up with this
button let's change these colors and
then we'll try to get the correct font
in here so let me see right now what
those are no this isn't the right I have
a lot of dev tools windows open right
now okay so this actually has a three
pixel border radius right now as well oh
look at that we did we definitely don't
want that so that's the bond focus all
right good to know I'm glad we that we
caught that so let's go over to our CSS
so I've since we're adding so much to
our CSS I started putting in some some
comments just to break it up so all
these are for the navbar these are for
the cards this is for buttons so
hopefully it'll make it easier if we
ever have to come back to this or
somebody else has to come back and edit
this at some point it'll make more sense
all right so first of all let's take
this good button focus okay that'll get
rid of those styles that we saw briefly
forgot my period oops and I forgot to
check the chat and start my timer so
let's get the timers started wherever it
is it is okay so let me do 25 minutes of
coding and then we'll take a five-minute
break and I'll come to the live chat so
if you have a question just hang on for
25 minutes and then I'll get to your
question
see cool Andrew in the live chat said
I'm a big fan so thank you so much
that's that's awesome that's actually
really cool that my stream has fans
anyway I'm glad you're here
glad you're in the live chat and unable
to join us so I really appreciate you
all who are able to join in the live
stream I appreciate everyone watching
but it's also really cool to have that
feedback in the live stream it's
definitely a different vibe whenever
there's nobody did my camera oh no ok I
thought it froze for a second but I was
looking at a different preview so we did
anyway what I was trying to say was it's
a it's just a different feel when
there's not that many people in the live
chat I I don't know if it's bad I
wouldn't say it cause say it's bad but
it's just it's very different so I kind
of like when there's when there's more
activity a hard shot I said you tested
the print view and PR 50 in the bulletin
I have not tested it yet so I'm gonna
test it soon probably I'll get back to
that project when I'm done with this but
like I think I mentioned yesterday I
really just want this to be ready I'm
just I'm getting a little bit nervous
because no one's been talking about it
here I don't know what the due date is
I'm just nervous that I missed something
or that it's not gonna be ready when it
needs to be ready so I'm trying to get
ahead of things oh you know what I just
saw - we don't want this color - the
underlined so we need to change that as
well so we're gonna we've already put in
the code you know we didn't we need to
put in border-radius
two pixels and that should take care of
it okay
you know let's let's check this let me
bring over my dev tools window and let's
pull this to the side so we can see what
we want to see here and yeah this is
definitely the input
interesting
okay yeah this is what we want so on
focus we want to change the color
awesome alright so let's grab this and
we'll change that color button so let's
let's put in input
let's let's put in this yellow so I
don't know if you remember from probably
stream a long time ago probably months
ago we had some discussion about the the
color this yellow color that's in the
palette so this is color I'm talking
about and in its original version it's
just too light to use on the web it's
hard to read so I converted it to this
format and was able to darken it just a
bit and then that little change made it
much easier to read so on a button it's
not a big deal but if you I rarely
rarely do font like this but on like a
thin thick place like this then it it's
useful to have it just slightly darker
so it's it's it's almost you'd have to
have the colors right next to each other
to really tell the difference but it's
that little bit of Darkness really helps
so I kind of like that I think it's the
third it was a hue saturation light and
I don't remember what the last one is I
think that's what it is
so anyway I believe it's this third
value here that you need to change to
darken or lighten an image or I'm sorry
a color okay so this is that's right
that's what we want now let's grab this
and I want to do two things to this
actually text occasion
so we want to change the color first of
all but then we also want to make sure
that we have a text-decoration:none no
matter what I don't really like the
underlined I think the cursor:pointer
will be fine I'm assuming we have that
yeah we do it should be by default on an
a tag anyway so let's grab all goodness
this is just the default a style all
right then
ling-su we want to put this I almost
want to put the styles that are more
Universal you know for a base element
like an a tag up at the top so let's put
that at the top that I know I didn't
copy out yet let's see
all right let's see what color I don't
want this blue but I do want whoa is
that for some reason we just got a
refresh it's okay
I want to I'm okay with the blue color
let's check out what we're currently
using here okay here we're using this
blue this blue is in the color palette
but I'm not really a big fan of it for
the web so let's see I'm pretty sure we
have links here
okay so we are using that yellow for
links okay we could try that I'm a
little bit hesitant to put the yellow
text right next to the yellow button it
might be too much so maybe we switch up
the button the only reason I really like
yellow for a button as it stands out now
this isn't really a call to action so
mut I'm not that worried about it but
for for a button that would be more of a
call to action I do like the yellow
stands out all right let's just see
since we have the hex code right here or
I shouldn't say the hex code because
it's not what we're using but since we
have this here we'll try that first if
not I'm gonna try to track down a blue
color that I know I'm using in a few
other sites that I do like better oops I
forgot we're not I don't have library
though alright so that was a good time
oops and you make sure we apply that to
both and then
let's just get all of them just to be
sure I'm not gonna test it out to see if
this is necessary it's just so quick to
to type this out all right so let's go
through our little flow here we're gonna
take our Styles move it into our
template we're gonna save that and then
we're going to take all of this and move
it over here now you'll see this looks a
little bit different I wanted to show
you all the newer version I think they
call it the lightning experience so this
with the newer version looks like and
also if you remember yesterday I was
super frustrated by how tiny this this
window was here with the with the code
so I went in dev tools and made it a lot
bigger I'm thinking about using
tampermonkey to write a script to just
change this but I don't know if it's
worth it it depends on how much I'm
going to be working with this if I'm
going to work with it a lot then it's
going to annoy me so maybe I will wear a
script but for now since I'm just copy
and pasting in there it doesn't really
matter
it'd be worse if I to edit it directly
okay let's check this out okay okay so
that's working out like we wanted two
buttons here the yellow I don't know how
I feel about that yellow
yeah I'm not sure I think I might change
it I think I'm gonna leave it for now
just kind of get used to it and then
maybe come back to it later on so let's
make a note let's see can you do inline
notes now you can't well at least let's
see if you could do this I don't think
you know what I think you can do it in
SAS but not in regular CSS
I don't really know it doesn't matter
I'll put it right here
okay
all right I'm just gonna look quickly oh
that actually changed that as well
that's interesting so I guess this is an
a tag and this is not actually I don't
really hate these being two different
colors I'm but I'm gonna revisit those
again
I really don't want to mess with the
colors too much well I have a different
font because the font the the type of
font and then especially the font weight
plays such a huge role in how things
look a color might be fine and with one
font and with another font it'll make it
unreadable so let's get the right font
in here now I keep saying we need to
change the font so let's just do it now
so I'm gonna go through I could just
copy the font from a other project but I
think it might be a good idea to go
through how to grab a font so we're
gonna get a Google font let's see so I
just typed in Roboto Google font am I
good at google fonts okay now there is a
home page the google fonts where you can
browse different fonts and pick what you
want so you can go to that if you're not
sure what you want but since we knew
exactly what font we wanted we're just
going to go right to it so you can see a
lot of information about the font but
what we want to do is select it so we're
going to go up here and select this font
and then we have this little you know
drawer down here and it'll give us
several options for how to embed this
font we can also customize the font so
we can see we can grab what we want so
right now we're just bringing in the
regular 400 font weight but I want to
bring in light medium bold
and I'm not sure if we're using italic
anywhere
yeah I'm not I'm not sure I'm not gonna
bring in any italic now if we find
somewhere where we see us our text will
bring this in but for now this is good
if we end up not using one of these font
weights we can always redo it later
because this is a lot to load it gives
you a low time estimate of moderate we'd
rather get it to be fast so I'm thinking
we actually might not need the medium at
some point but we'll see for now I'd
rather have it so that I could see what
they look like you can also pick
languages so we're gonna stick just with
Latin I'm I don't sorry I don't mean
languages in the sense of a I know it
says languages but these are really more
characters I'm not sure why they have
languages as the title there okay so we
can do it two different ways we can do
the standard way or we could use the
import and I'm not sure what would be
the best
hmm I don't know I think I'm gonna try
to do the standard way since we have
access if if I only had access to a
stylesheet it's nice that you can import
it as well but let's put this in right
above our style I'm gonna bring this in
and see you can see it it tells us all
our font sizes here and now we'll just
copy this and before I paste this into
our our style sheet
let's see where they're bringing in
their font if they're putting it on the
body tag or down lower let's see okay
they are oh they're bringing it on the
HTML tag okay that's interesting I think
will bring ours in on the body tag there
should not be anything that displays
outside of the body and that's true so
I'm gonna put it on the body tag
and I'm gonna do this like this so HTML
body that way I'm positive that at least
at this level my font family is more
specific than theirs so it should
override theirs we may find some cases
where they've added a font family you
know down lower or something more
specific but we'll we'll figure that out
when we get to it
so with these I want to test this out
and let's keep forgetting where I have
these windows
actually you know what I really want to
do whoa
Oh interesting so it's giving me an
error for my link tag interesting let's
see if I couldn't just do this okay so
it would not let me put this link tag in
without terminating the tag which is
fine um obviously we've been doing react
for so long we're used to doing that so
normally I would but since we just copy
and paste it in I didn't even notice
okay
anyway I was going to say if I end up
using tampermonkey to put a script in I
think I'm gonna put in a button that can
just make this fullscreen because I
don't need any of this stuff around the
edges it's just taking up a lot of space
and I'll never need to select anything
so that might be useful to have a nice
you know fullscreen I don't know what
these buttons do maybe there is a full
screen you know that's a search this is
like oh okay there is an undo redo
increase font size decrease this is the
most bare-bones editor of I've seen at
least it tells you the positions it's
probably hard to see that fonts are
really small but it does tell you your
the line numbers so not bad but very
basic ok let's see what this is
nice let's verify that we are getting
the correct font so we're just going to
click on a font here and we'll go to
computed and see computed is usually the
easiest way to find something specific
yep it's the right font
let's try one other place just to be
sure it all looks right but yep there we
go
okay wonderful great alright so with the
exception of a few things that we're
going to think about and maybe come back
to later on this is not bad
we may change this add some things I
don't know but I don't want to make any
serious design changes until I get some
input from other people at the
University here because it's honestly
going to be a waste of effort if other
people have strong opinions and more
authority than they permit it to how to
do something right now
okay let's see alright I got about four
minutes left and then I'll do question
answer so if you've been asking
questions just hang on for four minutes
and then I'll get to them okay now let's
check this sign up view and make sure
that it looks right if everything's
right with that then we're actually
going to sign in if you remember
yesterday we tried to sign in and it
looked a mess so we're gonna have some
work to do so let's sign okay
interesting interesting
maybe there's an inactive class I'll
have to check that out as to why these
colors are changing but this looks fine
it looks like all our styles are being
applied oh that's a problem I don't know
if you notice that when we need to let's
see what it does here
all right this spacing is fine but we
need to add some more space between this
and this
so before with the other font it was it
wasn't overlapping but now you can see
it's actually overlapping that T and the
GR overlap so that's not good this kind
of thing I don't want to make myself
sound like I'm an expert or anything but
I really think that when it comes to CSS
stuff attention to small details like
that are the difference between a really
good site in an okay site it's not the
type of thing that every user is going
to notice but if a user does notice it
it's gonna drop their confidence in your
brand or your company or anything at
least it definitely does for me if I
notice little things like that I think
if this company doesn't pay attention to
these little details on their own sites
are they gonna pay attention to the
little details when dealing with me with
whatever product or service that they're
offering so I've I've actually just
refused to look at anything else on a
company's web page because I noticed
little things like that or even bigger
problems and I think I basically just in
my head think if they don't care enough
about me as a user to fix these things
then that's not really the people that I
want to work with so at least to me it's
a big deal maybe it's just because I do
this and I notice those things but I
mean if you went to a building right and
the steps were all cracked and it was
hard to get in and it was kind of you
know dirty he it would be leave a bad
impression right it's the same thing
with a website you come to companies web
site and things aren't quite right it
makes an impact on people alright so and
enough of my my speech on CSS let's fix
this okay so our h1 let's grab this
class and application and title let's
let's put this down in the card Styles
section since we're inside the card
so in our card style section this this
is about the entire card the wrapper so
it makes sense that the title would be
underneath that so I'm trying to give
some structure to the CSS I'm not
following a specific methodology but
better to get do try to do something
then just have a mess of things which if
you've all watched the streams for
previous projects you know I have a
tendency to make a mess of the CSS if
I'm not careful okay so let's just
change this bottom margin a bit
margin-bottom and let's go with I know
they're doing EMS but I'm just way more
comfortable with pixels I can usually
tell how many pixels I need just by
looking at a thing and I can't with with
other units it's got a 24 because what
we really want oh yeah that's that's
much better let's zoom out of it yeah
perfect I like that
okay so let's grab this and paste it
over great okay I'm not gonna bother
testing this right now
it's pretty basic it should work and my
timer is just ran out so let's take our
five minutes do some question and answer
let me scroll up to the top and I'm
gonna work my way down and get to as
many questions and comments as I can if
I don't get to your question during this
session after our next 25 minute session
of coding then I'll get to all the
questions so red asks is it possible to
learn Python on free code camp so as far
as I know free code camp there there
exercises or challenges whatever they
call them it does not deal with Python
but potentially free code camp is more
than just those lessons so you have the
YouTube videos you have the forum you
now have the guide which deals with a
lot of different topics so there may be
other free code camp resources that
could help you learn Python but in terms
of the specific challenges that are on
the main free code camp site I don't
believe there's any Python in there they
are working on a new curriculum as far
as I know there's no Python in that
either I could be mistaken so if anybody
I know some of you that watch this are
also working on helping with other
things in free code camp so if I'm wrong
about that let me know but I tell you
where is a decent place
for me to pick up the little bit of
Python knowledge that I know is Udacity
is intro to computer science course uses
Python so if you also would like to get
some background in computer science and
learn Python at the same time that's
probably your best route if you are
already really confident in all these
computer science concepts and you just
need to learn Python syntax quickly then
that might not be the best for you you
might want to try out code academies and
browser exercises I believe they have
Python I'm not 100% sure it's been a
while since I was on their site but
those would be my top suggestions
hopefully that helps
okay harsh it says I have a question
what is the benefit of using Salesforce
let's see you may have used Google forum
for submissions yeah so the benefit with
Salesforce is really in I don't know how
much I don't want to show you too much
in the Salesforce because we have
student data that you're not supposed to
show anyone so I don't want to
accidentally show that on YouTube
because the university could get in a
lot of trouble for that and so could I
so I'm just gonna try to describe a
little bit about the other things that
Salesforce does this is probably I'm
sure you could check it out on their
website but basically the ability to
track and run reports on all the data
easily from a pretty simple user
interface is one of the strengths of
Salesforce there are a lot of other
additional things Salesforce can do with
that data like sending emails
automatically depending on what stage of
the journey they're in
you can get sales horses like you pay
for the base product and then you pay
for these add-ons so depending on what
add-ons you get it can do other things
were maybe going to get an add-on soon I
hope we do where we could define routes
a basically a decision tree for new
students or donors or whoever depending
on what actions they take they go
through entirely different route of
automated emails and mailings and phone
calls and different things that could
happen so that we can really customize
the experience for each prospective
student so that they get the materials
that are of most interest to them based
on you know where they're at what major
they're interested in what sport they're
interested in playing so I think it'll
be a nice it will help to automate a lot
of the work that we are having people do
right now that they probably there's no
need for them to do manually so that'll
be nice to free up some time for other
people but then it'll also be really
nice for the prospective students as
well so that they don't get a lot of
material that's irrelevant to them and
kind of a waste of their time to go
through so that's kind of the cool thing
that to me that I've seen that
Salesforce does there's so much more the
Salesforce does that I have never seen
or used so I don't want to limit it to
that there's also some machine learning
things that they're building in now that
I haven't used so it can do so much more
in this use case it's basically online
form right we could do this ourselves
and it would be easier honestly to build
out the form in just plain HTML CSS set
it to a Google sheet and be done with it
but we wouldn't have access to all those
other things and it wouldn't tie into
other systems that we have on campus so
anyway hopefully that explains it a bit
I am by far not a Salesforce expert so
I'm sure I'm not doing it justice in
terms of what it can do okay let me go
I was just checking now I don't think I
was hoping I'd get down to the bottom of
the chat but there's too much there now
so I'm just going to mark down where I
left off and we'll get back to it after
our 25 minute code session
okay
all right
so what was next all right we fix this
now we're gonna login
I thought did we log in yesterday why am
i logged out of I'm gonna grab the grab
what I need on this other screen
evidently I have several accounts for
this now that I'm checking in my my last
buzz okay
all right I should work
whoa wait wait wait hold on yeah you all
saw this yesterday right it did not look
like this yesterday it this is what did
we click on yesterday that looked so
crazy
all right we need to check this out
okay this is our video from yesterday
this is what it looked like yesterday
and then now it looks like this I'm
happy that it looks like that but I
don't know well hopefully at some point
we'll get this screen again and can see
what the problem is all right wow that's
pretty crazy okay
well I'm happy about this so the styles
that we've applied here and to the
button are still working as well as our
font so that's good news this might take
less time than I anticipated so let's go
ahead and start the online app
why
[Music]
why do they make me click that and then
click another button alright that's not
really something I can change I don't
think that was a good user experience
decision though all right let me see I'm
just kind of checking the font size is a
little small for me that looks like
twelve or fourteen yeah it's fourteen
let's make that bigger where are we
getting that fourteen from I like to set
my minimum font size at sixteen pixels
so how is this
Christian's contain
[Music]
Wow this one is at 12 point font yeah we
definitely need to make these bigger
these should both be at least 16 let's
see if we can see if we put it on here
on this element if we can get it to
affect the elements below it I don't
think so but it's worth a shot
whoops it's 16 no but can we get
here we go
no I don't want that now it affected
this font size as well all right I was
just trying to get around being really
specific with these classes but I think
we're gonna have to so let's go to this
one
I guess we could use not
yeah let's just do that let's try to use
and knots and knots will that work
yeah that worked awesome
I like that okay let me copy and paste
this and then explain what I did in case
you're not familiar with this selector
we're gonna put this under
let's go with loops do not mean to hit
that
let me make this a bit bigger I'm sorry
I should have made this bigger earlier
okay okay so here's what I did
hopefully you can see this you know what
I want to let me reset these settings is
I don't want this to get cut off by my
face so I need to set this so that we
can scroll past the bottom core settings
scroll past end okay that's a good
setting I I like to have this setting on
all the time I don't know how it got
turned off at scroll past end and Adam
lets us do this which can be useful if
you don't want to have things right at
the bottom of your screen so right now
here's what we're doing we've selected
that target X application percentage
container which was our full container
and then instead of having to go through
each one of these spans and select the
the class because we didn't want it to
apply to one of the spans so instead of
having to select each one of these
separately we just added a knot and then
put the class that we didn't want to
have in there
so this is so much more concise so
that's that's what we've done there in
situations like that it's it's really
nice and it saves some code alright it's
ok I'm ok with this the only thing I
might change I'm not worried about right
now is this red I don't understand why
they're going with red for that that
usually indicates that something's wrong
like an error so maybe it will change
that and see I'm just really interested
in seeing what it looks like when we
start so let's move on to that
okay not bad let's ensure that our
Styles okay so our button styles are not
applying whenever this disabled class is
there let's see what happens when we
apply okay great now our styles do take
effect so that's okay let's make sure
that our card styles are there it looks
like it but it can't hurt to
double-check target ex-con interesting
no they didn't apply okay but we do have
a nice class too to latch on to here so
we have this target X card so let's grab
that and we should be able to just add
this to our card styles and we already
have so here's our card Styles it's
interesting on that first page they
don't use this card class on what is
essentially a card so that's a little
bit odd okay but that should take care
of this card also I want to fix the same
thing that we had going on before with
the spacing let's see Target X
application form title let's make sure
okay great we should be fine
we just never pasted those styles over
so I'm not worried about that
let's see dab this blue color is on
these dropdowns so we may change that
and they are actually really small all
right I'm not going to change it right
now right now going through I'm trying
to differentiate between things that if
I have time I would like to do and
things that really should be done so
this category here of things are things
that I think aren't necessary to do so
we're gonna hold off on these what we
would do is change the color and the
size and positioning of these a bit so
that they're in here more but I'd rather
kind of go through everything and look
for major issues alright so let's start
now the problem with this application is
going to be that there are things that I
won't see depending on what choices I
make hopefully there's nothing like
really different that I should be seeing
it should just be what questions I get
shown or not oh all right so this is see
that this is a good illustration of the
difference
like this obviously is something that
needs change this is ridiculous
oh well interesting on this page these
arrows are much more reasonable in terms
of size
I wouldn't say errors what do they call
these Chevron's okay all right so the
only problems I see here right now are
the logo is way too small this button
needs styling and the text is way too
small in a lot of places here you know
down here inside this select this button
these styles oh do you see this we're
definitely going to take away that I'm
not a fan of this here yeah all right so
we're gonna take away that animation
let's see what happens
hmm that's a cool effect we'll want to
change the colors here of this sidebar
I think the font size should be larger
here I'm thinking more of on a phone it
that click the tap targets need to be I
would say at least 40 pixels tall and
that's there's no that's nowhere near 40
interesting this is going to need some
work on mobile I'm actually really
surprised that it looks like this one on
a mobile device I'm gonna have to I'm
not gonna do it on the stream since you
won't be able to see unless I get my
phone in but I'm not a fan of this I'm
surprised this should be centered maybe
it is centered in terms of the entire
width but they're not taking to account
this little sidebar and they should so
it should be centered it should exclude
this width and then be centered here
yeah so that definitely needs some work
there's no reason why we can't show the
logo as well I mean I'm all for a really
slim navbar on mobile because there's
not a lot of screen space but I think we
could stand to be a little bit taller
here and keep the logo otherwise there's
there's no branding at all for the
University okay let's see how much time
I have nine minutes all right
that would be a good time to make some
some notes about this because I just
noticed a lot of things I'm definitely
going to forget I'm after the
question-and-answer session so let's
grab a Trello board and make these
issues I mean normally well I wouldn't
say normally I was trying to test out
doing a github project instead of a
Trello board but I'm not even really
putting this on github right now so and
I don't know if I ever will so let's
just go with the Trello board
I forgot on Chrome Canary and I don't
have any much stuff save
alright I'm gonna make a new one and
potato
this first application and I'm just
gonna go with the blue for now okay I'm
not gonna do all my Kanban rows here
right now because I just want to get
these ideas out of my head and onto
something before I forget as fast as I
can
okay so let's say
[Music]
vacation and I'm gonna give these
estimates pompadour estimates while I'm
doing these I probably wouldn't need a
whole Pomodoro cycle to fix that but
it's easier to type 1 than 0.5 let's see
okay so the first three in case you
can't read these it's a fix button
colors in the in the nav here change the
side nav colors increase font size and
and items on the side nav change icon
colors and we're going to make all fonts
at least 16 pixels and let's let me
check this up because I think what's
happening is they're using gray instead
of black with opacity so let's double
check this I didn't give me what I
wanted
oh there
yeah see is this it so they're Gray's
are actual grace we don't want that we
want Gray's that are black with opacity
set and I can't find whether where they
have this label there it is let's see
okay yeah see that's great let me change
this right now just to show you what it
different so I'm looking I'm a zoom in
here on this name where it's his name
right here and let me change this so
let's bring this up and let's pick up
let's just pick a black so we're gonna
do black first and then actually let me
switch
No there we go
let's go 54 okay this is going to be
hard to tell because we we don't have it
side by side but basically hopefully
you're able to see and you can go back
and rewind the video and see it's so
much easier to read text that's black
with opacity with I'm sorry transparency
yeah you could say either way
transparency or opacity but basically
it's 54% is the standard that I do when
I want to do input fields 87% is the
standard color for all other text but
it's so much easier to read when you do
that as opposed to using a very similar
color but using the hex code for gray in
this case it was cccccc yeah I think
that was right so anyway that's just a
good tip that's actually in the material
design guidelines so I didn't make that
up myself or discover it myself but
anyway that's a good tip so let's just
say in our Trello board
okay all right
what else did I see
we remove that hover effect for these
buttons scroll down so required field
shows up as red I'm gonna have to think
about that that seems a little extreme I
have a show up that red let's see Center
courts on mobile let's see okay okay
not bad so far let me check my timer
alright I got a minute left so we're
gonna stop there we got a little bit
here down there so not not too bad all
the the big things are there Oh actually
I want to change the colors on these
indicators
there we go all right I'm just gonna
start with the question answer session a
little bit early since I don't there's
not that much I'd get done in another
minute so let me scroll up to where I
left off so at this point in the stream
I'm finished for the most part with the
coding portion so if you're not
interested in the question answer
session and that would be the time when
you might want to take off otherwise
please stick around and help answer
questions or ask some questions of your
own okay
and see
the heart rook said please add some
space between username and sign-in when
you click it yes that was exactly what I
was thinking so good call on that sorry
I didn't look over and see that sooner
okay
Harshad has some good advice here
Harshad says he found an online wire
framing software called Sigma fi GMA
which is as good as sketch and it is
free so check that out
I just heard of it so I can't recommend
it but check that out figma comm fi GMA
calm thanks for the say the suggestion
Harshit
John Hanson says with Google Fonts is it
ever worth it to actually put their CSS
into your code or best to leave as a
relative link
Harshit says I guess for Roboto it's
good to use the the link because it's
usually cached it's quite a popular font
yeah I agree
and I think that that would harsh it
said can apply across the board to
different JavaScript libraries and CSS
libraries and things if it's very
popular you might get better performance
in terms of load times by using the the
link from a CDN or something like that
if what you're using is not as popular
then you might get better performance by
having it you know within your code base
so it's a good idea when you come to the
testing phase for you know
site speed to try it either way then and
see what kind of results you get
it looks like those sign up and login
links that we were seeing on the first
page that for me were two different
colors were not two different colors for
some of you so maybe I thought we'd
changed it for visited as well right
didn't we do that yeah maybe
active there's got to be some sort of
active or inactive class that's going on
or off to check that out more closely
later on
that'll up probably fall under the
category of little things that don't
absolutely need done but if we have time
we'll do it
okay rook says the courses from Rice
University on Coursera are also good for
Python they're free to audit so awesome
thanks for for pointing that out rook
there's a lot of free courses out there
it is really good to hear what other
people say about the courses because
otherwise it's like which one do you
pick you know there's so many free
courses not just for you know stuff like
we do but all different fields
world's asked do you see things like
Salesforce take away possible dev jobs
in the future I I don't know that I know
enough about this to give a good answer
but based on what I do know here's what
I think the something like Salesforce
would help to cut down on a lot of
manual work that's done but not
necessarily by developers I'm talking
about data entry work manually filing
things manually making spreadsheets and
copying things over so in that sense I
don't think those are necessarily things
that devs would be doing and for
Salesforce if you want to do custom
things then you sometimes need a dev so
I can see it going another way and
there's now this whole niche of
Salesforce devs that can develop you
know add ons to Salesforce or change the
look right now with the level of
permissions that I have in Salesforce I
actually have higher permissions than
most other people from the University
because I need to access some some of
the code but I don't have permissions to
change everything but if I did I could
change the look of the the whole UI for
the the admin panel in Salesforce you
can change quite a bit so I imagine
there are dev opportunities because of
Salesforce where there weren't
opportunities before now certainly are
there going to be opportunities as many
opportunities for devs to build
something like this from scratch you
know proprietary systems for different
institutions no but I don't know that
that was a that'd be a good situation
anyway I that would be kind of a mess I
think to have to go in in every
different place has their own custom
built system I don't know so I guess my
short answer is I'm of the opinion that
this would not take away depth
it might just shift dev jobs
Harshit says did your famous IT
department finished the single sign-on
yes they did actually let me let me show
you what this single sign-on looks like
I don't think I showed you this I did
work on some of the styles it didn't
turn out exactly like I would like I
wanted it to but it was a weird workflow
where I couldn't edit any Styles
directly I had to send them to the head
of the IT department and then she
forward them on to another company and
then somebody at that company had to
actually put the styles in we had a lot
of trouble going back and forth where
the code that I gave them didn't get
inputted into the right place or
properly and so finally I just tried to
make as complete of style sheets as I
could and then send them and say exactly
where to put them and then for the most
part it worked out but there's still a
lot of would change but the the feedback
loop was just so slow like we're talking
like weeks before I could see what the
changes were so I did what I could do
you know considering all the other
projects that I had going on so you all
could go to the login screen if you
wanted to it's access FUS dot franciscan
ddu you won't be able to get past the
login screen though so let me show you I
actually can log in as a student or as a
staff member Oh Logan as a staff member
I think there's more to see there so
basically the background image wasn't my
decision that was already there when I
started working on it I don't know that
I would have put a background image
there but there were so many other
issues that I just left that alone there
is one cool thing that you can see here
in the image that's kind of weird I
don't know how many people noticed this
but it was a like a long exposure photo
so some students were walking here and
you can see a couple things one you can
see a shadow on the wall but you can
also see this faint outline of so
a student's shoe in their leg so it
looks like there's a ghost there
so anyway cool little easter egg that I
don't know how many people will notice
but anyway you can see I added the
proper card style shadows border-radius
the right effect for the button changed
the font to Roboto another thing that's
really weird is this look at that that's
an image I have no idea why they
couldn't just put in text I'm pretty
sure that's an image inside of an H tag
that's another one of those things that
I recommend it to them to change and it
didn't get done so I just left it alone
they are using the older logo on on this
screen which is fine I think it works
better in this situation once we log in
we'll see the newer logo so we have the
new logo here we have the the newer
styles for the header I would have liked
to have done more with a search but like
I said there are a lot of other problems
this black line was added after I
already submitted all my Styles I would
not have this this thick and this color
I would make it much thinner and a grey
color but maybe you know this will be
the next round of changes I'm hoping now
that it's completed we'll actually have
more access to do some changes on our
own but I'm not sure I also made these
work cards kind of but they didn't have
the right style so now they have the
right styles the border radius the
shadows a hover effect since they're all
clickable I have a hugger cover effect
normally I don't recommend a hover
effect on a card unless the entire thing
is clickable so anyway the university
bulletin is on here currently and that's
what we've been working on as the
project for I think so I'd love to have
it integrated into this I think they're
using a saml for a single it's the
single sign-on so still need to talk
more with the IT department to get in
there their last suggestion
why don't you just make it so that you
can only see the bulletin if you click
on this link within here I don't think
that's the best idea
I mean it's I'm not even sure how it
would implement that and it would
actually be secure but even if I could
then that would mean that nobody could
actually go directly to the bulletin so
any bookmarks of the bulletin wouldn't
really work you'd have to come through
here so rather not do that so we'll see
hopefully you can get it integrated
better so anyway this is it you click on
it you're automatically logged in so not
bad I'm actually I'm really excited that
they got this working it's something
that they've wanted for a really long
time and yeah so I'm happy I'm proud of
the IT people for you know getting this
together and working so and I'm happy
that you know they asked me to work on
the Styles too so that was really cool I
think well it shows that they know that
I'm I'm good at this I guess or good
enough that they wanted me to do it and
that they care about the look of the
sites which i think is awesome
so always happy to collaborate with
other departments whenever possible and
so this was cool
and that's cool the head of the IT
department is really nice she's a really
smart woman and I enjoy working with her
so so this was kind of a cool project
just a little one but it was nice
alright let me go back to the live chat
Oh on Anson's has going to the gym for a
workout my wife somin is making me go
what can I say well I guess you gotta
gotta keep your wife happy right that's
your marriage means more than then
you're coding right keep it in
perspective so see you tomorrow it's on
okay Blake says thanks for the pool
request but now everything is undefined
okay so earlier today I submitted a pull
request to one of Blake's projects yeah
so let me so here's what I was you're
getting undefined
everything is undefined
what are your here's what I would check
Blake what are your headers look like on
your Google sheets
because that's what because if you if
you're actually getting information to
go to your Google sheet and saying
undefined then that means a lot is that
is going right so that's a good sign
but we need to make sure that one the
data getting sent is in the right format
which it ought to be
you just need serialized data and then
we also need to make sure that the
headers match up exactly with the names
so let me okay let's check this out
Blake do you mind if we check this out
on on the live stream right now I don't
want to check it out if there's any data
in there that we I shouldn't show but it
would be cool to show everybody a little
bit more about how this works so just
let me know I'll open it on and on okay
cool all right so let's open this up
here and let me get rid of this dot and
this asterisk okay okay here's this is
SSS
okay so we have this awesome let's put
in another row that that should be
helpful another column I mean come on
another clone won't you let me put
another oh it's view only I'm gonna send
a request for edit access if you don't
want to give it to me that's fine I'll
just tell you what to do here but I'd
like to add another column for the time
stamp because that can be helpful let me
check out the repo as well
oops on the wrong wrong repo
okay let me see
oops dang it
okay
good timestamp and let's make sure
okay it looked like there was a space at
the end of named so that potentially
could be that could have been the
problem with name so let's see so that
may work now and let's see
that's fine double-check this yeah okay
let me show you I think I still have my
stuff up
okay so this is so this is exactly how I
had it set up so I was able to get
everything to come through at at one
point so it looks like
hmm interesting
yeah I'm I'm pretty sure the issue with
the name was that extra space at the end
so that should work now because that was
consistently undefined
let me check out I mean if you want to
test that again maybe it'll work yeah
gasps is that a SteelSeries Siberia
headset by the way those are really
comfortable
yes it is that's crazy that you were
able to identify the headset from my
tiny you know video in the corner
they're so cool yeah I actually I really
like these
SteelSeries headsets I've been using
them for and I think at least three
years and they're great I get they are
really comfortable occasionally my ears
will hurt but only if I've been coding
like all day and taught it like for like
ten hours if I've had them on ten hours
plus otherwise it's great audio quality
I don't really know I'm not really an
audiophile so they sound good to me it
would be nice if they had a little bit
more bass but it's not it's not a huge
deal they're they sound good and it
keeps the rest of the noise out from you
know other things going on so it keeps
me focused over the under fight says you
won't be able to get past a login screen
though is that a challenge
actually yes if anybody can get into
this access FUS somehow get to this
screen and prove that you got to that
screen then I don't know what you'll get
you'll definitely get a shout out on the
live stream at the very least but that
would act that would really be awesome I
would I wouldn't call out the IT
department but I would like quietly just
go to the head of IT and say you might
want to check this out so that's how I
prefer to handle things I have a lot of
respect for the head of the IT
department so I don't like to publicly
call anyone out on stuff I'd rather give
her the chance to you know handle it
with her team quietly and I appreciate
when when they give that same chance to
me if something's wrong on my site so
I'm a big believer and like going
directly to a person privately when
something should be changed instead of
calling them out publicly calling
someone out publicly in my mind should
always be the absolute last resort
because you can't ever take that back
okay so I just saw one go in here does
this mean that it works let me see
all right cool thanks it's working yay
all right and Blake if you I did change
a lot of stuff for the Google the Google
Apps Script stuff so if you want me to
explain why I change the things I did
let me know otherwise I mean if you can
check it out and figure out what's going
on then you know that's that's good too
but I'd be happy to explain a little bit
what I did I didn't really change that
much at all with with the code that's on
the site with the HTML or the JavaScript
the the biggest changes were in that
Google Apps Script and that's only
because I I have used it I don't know
maybe a half a dozen times on other
sites successfully so I just pulled a
lot of that code from my other site
since I knew that it was already working
okay Blake says and I'm assuming because
of the Google script it sends the form
to me but it won't send it to test a
test comm yes so that area where I put
test to test comm so let's check this
out let's check out the script editor so
if you've never seen this in Google this
is really cool so on Google sheets you
can have you can run JavaScript right in
here this does not handle any es6 or
beyond so just be aware of that that's
why we're doing this ridiculous stuff
here with concatenating all these
strings and variables uh-huh instead of
using template literals so I actually I
I am part of a very large string on the
the forums for Google Apps Script asking
for es6 support but that's been going on
for like two years so I don't know if
they'll ever have it or when otherwise
this is really cool so you can see when
we're sending the emails okay it looks
like you already changed that I'm really
sorry if you didn't want that email
shown on the live buddy I can't do
anything about it now so sorry about
that but anyway yeah so you can hard
code the two email that you want to get
so either your email or the email of
whoever needs to be checking this at the
company that you're building this for
and then for this email that the user
gets it pulls the email from its you
know Eid up for a murdered email so it's
just pulling that out from obviously an
object and then so that's why there's
two different templates because for the
user right now we're keeping it simple
and just saying you know hey we should
receive your submission as a subject
thank you of course you can add anything
else you want but then for the person
that's actually receiving they need the
data right they need to know name email
phone message so that's why we have two
different templates and we're doing two
different sends also I don't know how
you have this set up if email is not a
required field which I recommend it
should be
but so we don't get an error we have
this send in an if statement so it'll
only attempt to send it if there is an
email otherwise you'll get an error so
that's why we wrap this in an if
statement but like I said I would
recommend making the email first of all
validating that it's a valid email and
then also making it required so anyway
I'm glad I can help with that so I mean
i said i'm i'm really happy to help i've
done it before so i've gone through
quite a bit of oh no no more access how
that's cool
i've gone through quite a bit of
troubleshooting with google sheets and
sending form data Google sheets so no
sense in you having to go through all
that work better to share my information
with you and save you a bunch of time
okay let me go back through Michael says
the background image has ghosts I think
I saw Slenderman in there somewhere also
yeah it is weird I didn't even notice it
somebody in the IT department noticed it
and told me and I thought we were gonna
try to get a different image in there or
Photoshop that out but I guess that
didn't happen so I don't think it's a
huge deal I think it's kind of a cool
little easter egg but I don't know maybe
we'll probably switch that image my boss
looked at it today and said he wants to
switch out the image so it'll probably
happen at some point
our suits is switching to Kali Linux now
I will get through now if you if you
don't know what Kali Linux is then
you're not a hacker number one but also
Kali Linux is Linux that comes preloaded
with all these penetration testing tools
in there so if if you're white hat
therefore penetration testing to use it
for good if your black hat then then
they're hacking tools that can be used
for for evil so if you're interested in
that kind of thing check out Kali Linux
if you intend on using it for evil
though then you didn't hear it from me
uh-huh see
okay Blake says how do I redirect it to
a thank you page okay so you want to
thank you page to come up after the
after the forum successful form
submission yeah you could since you're
using javascript to submit the form I
actually recommend that you don't
redirect to an entirely new page because
that would cause a page refresh and
that's unnecessary what I think might be
better let's bring this up I think I
have it on another screen okay so what I
think might be better is when you submit
the form you have equal either a modal
pops up or something in the submit
button maybe a little checkmark and it
turns green something like that telling
people that it was submitted
I like that for two reasons one you
don't get a page refresh which is nice
but also it allows the user then to
immediately fill out the form again in
case they want to would they really want
to I don't know but potentially maybe
they they didn't put in the full message
or they put in the wrong thing and
didn't realize it till they sent it then
they won't have to you know do any type
of navigation at all they can just redo
it so that's my recommendation and if
you wanted to do that then
what you want to do then is in your
contact j/s here where it's this dot
done do something that's where you'll
want to do you know whatever so like you
might want to do so maybe submit form
something like this because that's the
button right and maybe you could just do
like CSS color background color and then
do I don't know like green something
like that would probably work so check
that out if you're interested and want
me to submit a pull request for that I
can definitely do it I mean I I already
have this in here otherwise this is
where you'd want to do it and just make
sure that the submit button is still
active if they want to resubmit that
would be that would be my suggestion I
usually do modal's that pop up and say
hey you know this worked but you don't
you don't have to get that complicated
with it just something really simple
down here a check mark icon anything I
think would work
okay Blake says thank you you welcome
Blake no problem oh cool Arshad says I
started learning ethical hacking last
month it's good cool yeah I've always
wanted to get into stuff like that
mainly to do penetration testing on my
own sites and make sure that they're
secure but I just really have in that
time to get into it maybe one day
Blake asks do an alert I wouldn't do an
alert like not a JavaScript alert so I
actually never recommend never doing
JavaScript alert on JavaScript alerts on
production sites it's so much nicer if
you can actually make a modal that will
appear because then you have much more
control over the Styles cool okay so
Blake Blake's gonna do it himself all
right that's cool Blake just let me know
if you have any trouble with it I think
you'll be fine though Harshit says I
will try a DDoS and sequel injection
okay now officially I did ask you all to
try to do this so if if you get in
trouble for attempting to hack a
university website make sure you tell
the authorities that I'm a developer at
this university and I asked you to do
this test thing I don't want anybody
getting in trouble for her for doing
that so I'll probably get in trouble at
that point but I don't want you all
getting in trouble so see I'm doing
these
oh cool Blake said I'm doing the u.s.
I'm trying to read how I would read this
CyberPatriot competition this year
that's cool I haven't heard of that
competition what was it for
okay
ok so it's a competition for securing
networks and computers awesome that
sounds really cool you have to let me
know when the competition is and how it
goes so I'm I'm interested to hear how
you do inflate gas how do how do I reset
it so how would you reset the form then
put it up there we go I think by default
it depends on what you want to do if you
go with if you go with the modal then
you could just have us if you click
outside of it it goes away or you can
put a closed you know like a little X
icon there if you go with something down
here you could maybe do it so that when
any of these inputs get focused it just
resets this that's that's probably how I
would do it because if they focus on an
input then that means they probably want
to want to change what they've done
there
okay
cool rug says I finally made the
livestream when it was going score
awesome glad you could make the
livestream ok Orson says I will not try
I don't want to get in trouble yeah I
didn't even think about it until just a
minute ago like that's probably not a
good idea to have everybody try to to
hack that site just because I don't I
don't know what the laws are in other
countries but I've heard that in the
United States at least like the laws are
pretty strict about attempting to hack
even if you don't intend to do any harm
like but you could still get you can you
still go to jail for that so I mean like
I said technically I'm giving you
permission but it may not even be it's I
probably don't have the authority really
to give you permission to do that but if
you happen to see anything that would
seem like something's off with the
security you know let me know and I'll
try to check it out yeah I mean I would
imagine some of the yeah there's
definitely some stuff we wouldn't want
people to have access to so anyway I
have gotten to the bottom of the live
chat so I think I'm going to end the
stream now to Thomas yeah pretty decent
length of the stream we're coming up on
almost two hours here so oh alright I
get exhausted after these streams they
like I love doing them but it definitely
takes a lot of energy okay so thanks
everybody for helping and for watching
the stream and anyway I'm really glad
that I could help you out with your
project lake so if anybody
everyone's help with your project let me
know the best thing would be to send me
the github repo because then I can
actually see all the code but I'm more
than happy to help I don't always have
time to do things right away but I'll
try to get to it when I can so I should
be back tomorrow
what's sorry Thursday Wow tomorrow's
Friday the week just went by so fast
yeah so I'll be back tomorrow probably
around the same time 2 p.m. Eastern time
and I think we'll be working on on
finishing up this the styles for this I
think it will take less time than we
anticipated or at least that I
anticipated so maybe we'll be able to
finish this up tomorrow and then then
move on to something else so thanks
again for watching and until tomorrow
have a great day